في اليوم الثامن وبعد قليل في اليوم
التاسع اختلفت الصوره والمشهديه وايضا
التقديمات الاساسيه والمساعدات في هذه
المدينه ويبدو الى ان هنالك دفع من قبل
الشركات الخاصه بالحكومه التركيه
والجامعات والمنظمات الاهليه الى مزيد من
كل التقنيات الحديثه لعمليه تقديم الاغاثه
هنا في هذه الشركه التي هي مطعم في الاساس
في اسطنبول وفي انقره وعندها عده من
المطاعم قامت اليوم بنصب هذه الخيمه والان
هؤلاء مجموعه من المتطوعين يقومون بطهي
الطعام الذي يوزع مجانا على كل من هو قائم
في هذا المخيم بالاضافه ايضا كما نشاهد
هذا الجزء الثاني من ياتي الى هنا وهذا
المركز يضم ما يقارب ثلاثه الى اربعه الاف
من النازحين في الداخل التركي بالاضافه
الى النازحين السوريين اذا ذهب الى هذه
السيارات
طاهر هذه ما هي هي سيارات البث
للتليفونات الذي لا يملك لا يملك هاتفا
خلويا يمكن له ان ياتي الى هناك ثم بعد
ذلك يجري الاتصالات ما يسمى بالخط الارضي
كل ما هو تقني وحديث ومتطور قام المنظومه
الاقتصاديه والاجتماعيه والسياسيه في
تركيا بجزه ودفعه الى الاماكن التي حصل
فيها هنا ايضا يقدمون الشيء الساخن ايضا
ايضا في هذه الخيمه التي سترى فيها يعني
ترى فيها الغرابه او ايضا العجابه من
الامر كيف وصلت الامور في اداره عمليه
المساعدات والتقنيات سنذهب الى هذه الخيمه
وايضا سنرى الان ماذا يجري
نرى
مواطنه تركيه تحمل مجموعه من الخبز هو
الان الساخن سندخل الى الداخل ايضا
ونشاهد ماذا الذي يجري نشاهد الخبز الساخن
كيف يجري ويتم توزيعه مباشره على كل من هو
موجود في المدينه هنا ايضا هذا الطحين هذه
الالات هذه مجموعه من المتطوعين وايضا علم
هذا الفرن ركب على عجل على عجاله او على
عشر من امره كما نشاهد الان الخبز في
الفرن ايضا يخبز ثم بعد ذلك يؤتى الى هنا
كما نشاهد العمال
هنا في هذا الجزء الخبز الذي ايضا يعمل
مباشره هو على مدار ال 24 ساعه لربما يقدم
العشرات من الاطنان الجاهزه في هذا المخيم
كما تشاهد الان هذه العمليه بالاضافه ايضا
نتحدث عن ثلاثه عناوين اساسيات الخبز
الطعام
مشرب الشراب الساخن ايضا الى الخيم الطبيه
التي وصل عدد كبير من الاطباء الممرضين
الممرضات هي دوره اقتصاديه اجتماعيه معي
شيا قائمه بحد ذاتها في كل المخيمات التي
اقيمت على الاراضي التركيه بالاضافه ايضا
الى ان هذا المركز هو مركز توزيع الى
المناطق الاخرى نعم
طيب تمام انا لازلت معك اذا ممكن بس تبعد
شوي محمود لانه في البخار اعتقد عم بياثر
على عدسات الكاميرا
لا حتى الكاميرا يعني لانه
خليلنا الصوره عندك لو سمحت عمليات اغاثه
دخل شيء ايضا
مشاكل اتوا بالشاورما التي هي كانت موضوعه
في اماكن متعدده ومن اراد ان ياكل عليه
فقط ان ينتظر لنصف ساعه وياخذ يحتاج كل
الحاجات الاساسيه التي يتطلبها
الانسان في معيشته هم لربما حصلوا عليه
لربما الصوره الان يعني ساذهب الى الخارج
حتى نكون من قضيه درجه الحراره هؤلاء
المجموعه من الناس ينتظرون الان لاخذ ما
يريدونه بالاضافه ايضا الى هذه المجموعه
من الطحين المقدس وهذا يعمل به على مدار
24 ساعه كما اشرت معك يظهر يظهر الى ان
هنالك دفع جديد بكل ما يحتاجونه من من
طعام من مواد من شراب من تقديمات على عكس
كنت قد استمعت معك الى السؤال للزميل عن
الواقع السوري وواقع التركي بالاضافه ايضا
كما نشاهد الان الشاي الذي يقدم وهذه
منصات او هذه مواقع هي موجوده ليست هنا
بالعشرات بل هي بالمئات وهي موزعه نحن كنا
نقوم بجولات متعدده على طول على طول هذه
المدينه ووجدنا هذا هذا الشيء وايضا هذه
التقديمات المترابطه مع بعضها البعض والتي
تدار من غرفه عمليات مركزيه
موحده هذه غرفه العمليات عندها القدره
لتعرف من هو الان من الفرق الذي يعمل في
الانقاذ على طول الاراضي التركيه من هي
الفرق التي وصلت من الشاحنات والمواد
الغذائيه الى الاراضي التركيه
حتى انه الخشب اذا تحدثنا عن الخشب بالامس
واليوم وصلت كما ترى درجه الحراره تقراي
تقريبا تحت الصفر وصل العشرات من الشاحنات
التي تنقل الحطب وقامت بتوزيعه بكل
الشوارع من يريد الخيام متوفره مواد
التدفئه متوفره
الاغذيه متوفره الادويه متوفره لكل من
يحتاجها في هذه الخيم وهذا جيد جدا
بالنسبه الى الاتراك وكل من كان مقيما
واستفاد من ذلك هناك ولكن للاسف لا يبدو
هذا على المقلب الاخر في الجانب السوري
كما قلنا على الاطلاق انما الحاجيات كبيره
جدا وهي حاجات ماسه بالنسبه الى المتضررين
يعني ولكن بدون شك الكل يريد ايواء دائما
وعوده الى البيوت بعد ترميمها او الى بيوت
جديده بدون شك محمود هذا امل الناس هناك
الان
طاهر معك تفضل
انظر الى هذه الحافلات الان التي تنقل
ايضا
المتطوعين الذين ياتون من المناطق
ويوزعونهم على مناطق العمل كيف نشاهد
هؤلاء مجموعه من المتطوعين ايضا مجموعه من
العمال هذا في
الباص الاول نرى هنا الباص الثاني نرى
ايضا الباص الثالث كل الامور هنا منظمه
حتى انها منظمه بالملبس يعني كل فريق ننظر
هنا كل فريق له لباس خاص به كل مجموعه لها
لباس خاص بها وكل مجموعه لها لها
كنت اسالك عن وعود التي قدمت الى الناس ما
الذي يقولونه الناس ما الذي يقولونه لك
بخصوص الوعود التي قدمت لهم للمده التي
يمكن ان يقضوها في اماكن الايواء المؤقته
وما البدائل
طائر من الصعوبه بما كان الحد من الصعوبه
بمحل ماء الحديث عن هذه المساله لان نحن
في المدينه التي نحن بها هي مدينه زلزلت
من اصلها الى فصلها الى فروعها والحل
الاساسي بها ان تقوم الحكومه بانزالها على
الارض كل الاحياء ثم بعد ذلك يبنى على
الشيء مقتضاه بعمليه البناء ولكن ايضا اذا
وفقنا في اليومين المقبلين سنذهب الى
مخيمات بدا العمل فيها ما يسمى بالكونتينر
مدينه باكملها
موزعه هم بداوا اليوم بوضعها غدا علمت الى
انهم سيقومون بتوزيعها بوصل الكهرباء ثم
بعد ذلك المفارقه او المشاهدات الحيه هو
انه عندما زرنا هذا المكان انظر هنا فقط
كذلك طاهر العمليات ايضا وغرف المستشفيات
المستشفيات الثابته والمستشفيات
متحركه وايضا بالقرب من هذه بالقرب من هذا
المخيم توجد ايضا مستودعات مليئه مليئه
بالادويه يعني الادويه المخزنه الادويه
المنظمه هي هنا بهذا الطريق يعني كان
بالامس حاولنا الدخول الى هذا الى هذا الى
هذا المخيم فطلبوا منا انه عدم الدخول
اليه حرصا على على المرضى او حرصا منهم في
بالقرب منه كما نشاهد هذا المخزن المليء
من الادويه بالاضافه ايضا الى هنا الخيام
المتوزعه والمتنوعه والتي يوجد فيها اما
جماعه من المتطوعين واما ايضا من الاتراك
واما ايضا من السوريين وكما نشاهد ايضا
الحطف في الارض هو وصل الى هذه المدينه
اقله بمجم
ليس بمئات الاطنان لربما بالاف لانه على
الطريق كنا نشاهد هذا الحطب المقسم
والمجزا والمقطع والمجهز ايضا
للنار حتى انه ترى العجابه الى انهم في
هذه الايام صنعوا مدافئ من حديد جاهزه
ومركبه للطرقات يعني لربما انت تضع هذه
المدفاه بقربك مباشره ثم بعد ذلك تقوم
بوضع الخشب بها ثم بعد ذلك بالتدفئه
بالتالي نتوقع ان يكون حال الناس بان
الحكومه استطاعت ان تمتص الصدمه ونقمه
الناس وان تحتوي الموقف ولو لم يكن ذلك في
اليومين او الايام الثلاثه الاولى هذا حصل
يعني على الاقل في المركز حيث انت ووفق
مشاهداتك ووفق ما تسمع من الناس
نعم صحيح الكلام الان الى ان الامور بدات
تاخذ مجراها الطبيعي على مستوى عوده دوره
الحياه الى طبيعتها بمعنى اننا جئنا الى
هنا في اليوم الاول زرنا كان هذا المكان
يوجد فيه اقله اقله عشره الاف مواطن تركي
الان يوجد فيها مجموعات مجموعات متخصصه مع
بعضها تقدم المعونه من بقي دخل الى الخيام
من لم يبقى ذهب
ذهب به او اخذ الى محافظات اخرى او الى
مدن اخرى من تبقى ايضا سيذهب الى
الكونتنيرات في المدينه الطعام
يقدم هنالك مطابخ سندخل في الساعات
القادمه الى كيف تطبخ الطعام وايضا ايضا
بالليل امس مع ساعات الفجر نزلت البلديه
لكنس الشوارع كان لافتا الى ان مدينه
باكملها على الارض
عشرات من العمال البلديه وهم يكنسون
الشوارع